well speaking of family we saw online
that you that y'all got guinea pigs
recently did you get your kids
oh my God your dog gets along with your
guinea pig
my dog tried to eat our guinea pig when
we were little
my dog traumatic my dog
um likes to eat other animals feces so
she likes to hang out that's a dog thing
no when we had the cat she was all up in
the kitty litter box yeah and now with
the guinea pigs she's just straight up
like mouth to the butt just
like a feeder yeah yeah
but you know I love guinea pigs my wife
wasn't sure about it and what happened
was my mom uh she works at NIH National
Institutes of Health in Bethesda
Maryland and at the time this was like
25 years ago they used to do
um animal experiments like they used to
dissect rats and and things like that
and once once upon a time they got this
guinea pig in the lab and everyone fell
in love with it and I showed up and I
was like Mom you can't please don't cut
this guinea pig open oh my God I love
this dramatic yeah I was like please and
my mother being the sweet woman that she
is stole the guinea pig from NIH she
smuggled that in a cardboard box and
picked me up from school one day and
there she was and so and that guinea pig
lived with us for years probably several
you know medical issues and things like
that but yeah she was there with us for
like four or five years so when chiate
my daughter said she wanted guinea pigs
I was like we gotta do it
a huge part of my childhood emancipating
one from a government facility this is a
movie yeah statute of limitations is
over so okay yeah you can't do anything
to my mother
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]